the images you are about to see are not
pictures but parables intended to ambush
reality
the images invite you to construct the
Gothic cathedral or not go down with a
neon
it's imaging of heaven its location in
time and in the earthly City its design
in the measure of man and heaven its
construction is structural behavior and
fragility and the power of its forms and
spaces revealed through the metaphor of
Daedalus is flight
in the clouds we catch a glimpse of
heaven the celestial city is
superimposed upon the earthly city Roman
Amy and we see the grid system of the
Roman city the late Roman city wall and
the anticipation of the Gothic cathedral
the late Roman city turned into the
medieval city with its industrial
northern suburb enclosed inside
twelfth-century walls we find ourselves
dropping on the city dense pack houses
crammed inside the recently constructed
wall population between 15 and 20
thousand people living in two and
three-story wooden houses dominated by
the massive chalk bulk of the Gothic
cathedral
as we skim over the rooftops the
Cathedral turns to reveal itself first
the West facade and then the southern
flank
it is through the myth of leaderless
that we are able to fly like gods or
goddesses we can comprehend the entirety
of the Cathedral the cruciform shape of
the translated the flying buttresses the
central spire
with Daedelus we fly with Icarus we fall
through the nave roof in vaults
and at our feet we see on the nave floor
the labyrinth known in the Middle Ages
as the house of Daedalus at the center
of the labyrinth the octagonal plaque
celebrates the creativity of the three
architects and the founding bishop from
this plaque we take the first master
mason Robert of Lesage and as we listen
to the music of peloton composed as the
cathedrals being built Robert will
demonstrate for us his method of design
the cathedral is built in the measure of
man and of heaven it is laid out using
the Roman foot about twenty nine and a
half centimeters as Robert walks he
leaves behind him a trail of foot units
the feet are gathered into 10-foot
squares which are themselves gathered
into a great central square of 50 feet
Noah's Ark was 50 cubits the Cathedral
50 feet they are both vehicles of
salvation
the square turns into a space matrix and
the for crossing peers are located the
span of the aisle is created by means of
a golden section the square is haft the
diagonal of the half square is rotated
giving us a 5 to 3 relationship 50 to 30
feet the image turns gold to indicate
the golden section the central 50-foot
square is surrounded by a peripheral
space of 30 feet creating a double
square this is the image of heaven that
we saw at the beginning heaven is
encoded in the central space of the
cathedral the spaces of the cathedral
are unfolded outward from the Great
Central Square using dynamic geometry
first come the transept arms rotating
out words like windscreen wipers
next the diagonal of the great square
swings to give the length of the nave
creating a square root of two rectangle
the half diagonal gives the length of
the choir creating the great cruciform
shape
the same strategy gives the choir aisles
the center point of the hemicycle
is located slightly to the east of the
last division we find this point using
the diagonal of the choir
and from this Center is struck the
hemicycle
and radiating chapels
the Bay divisions are inserted and the
height of the edifice is found through
the rotation upwards of the Great
Central Square the cathedral is built ad
quadratum
the resultant space matrix has a kind of
platonic clarity and beauty
this was the vision of the cathedral
entertained by Robert of Lesage and the
clergy at the start of work in 1220
however fifty years of construction of
push and shove separated the vision from
its final realization we will now watch
the cathedral going up
work began along the southern flank of
the nave with the West facade the north
navel follows a little later
Robert of Lesage was probably asked by
the clergy to create a provisional
liturgical space that would serve for
the immediate celebration of the offices
in this way the South nave aisle and the
south transept aisle were finished in
the first five years of work
with the North may vial completed soon
afterwards probably around 12:30 Robert
of Lesage died and was succeeded by his
former collaborator thomas of chroma
in the 12 thirties and 1240 master
Thomas constructed the upper nave
simultaneously laying out the lower
choir
bells were hanging in the southwest
tower by 12 43
Thomas of Como died in the later 12 40s
with the upper nave complete he was
succeeded by his son
Renault of Cornwall who in the 12 50s
and 12 60s constructed the upper transit
and choir Renault changed his father's
forms introducing a different type of
triforium and a different flying
buttress
the choir fliers are placed too high and
are too light to be effective runner
thus becomes a type of Icarus a
disobedient son destabilizing the
authority of his father structural
system the upper choir was finished
towards 1269 the flying buttresses built
by Renault of chromel are ineffective
they are placed too high in relation to
the main vaults in the late Middle Ages
the main supports buckled the fliers
were dislocated
the cathedral was saved through the
insertion of an additional flyer placed
underneath the original support
we enter the model in order to explore
its spatial complexity the model becomes
a linear matrix echoing the linear
intensity of garthok we move down the
South navel into the crossing space
sensing the diagonal expensiveness of
the crossing area
we enter the double aisle of the choir
and circumnavigate the ambulatory
leaving the radiating chapels to our
right
we return along the choir North aisle
back through the crossing space
into the nave
entering the nave main vessel and
looking upward we sense that the
building is made of squares the aisle
vaults are perfectly square the nave
vaults are double squares we approach
the Great Central Square into the
crossing space the crossing piers are
slender and are pushed inwards by arcade
walls meeting of 90 degrees
the piers buckle and would have
collapsed
the collapse was averted in the late
Middle Ages through the addition of a
massive iron chain that pegs the piers
in place
with an anagogical upward lifting
conclusion we end where we began in the
heavens
years ago we started talking about
developing a video program on the basis
of art humanities the idea was that
there was an audience out there waiting
for it I mean just as we would put
together a course we would be able to
send our best instructors as it were
over the networks through the wires and
so forth that has now developed I think
much more actively much more dynamically
into what we're doing now it is it
becomes increasingly possible to make
much more articulate the experience of
architecture both in terms of the viewer
as spectator as moving spectator through
space but also in terms of the analysis
of construction intellectually it will
be amines I hope that a department that
prides itself on being one of the best
or perhaps the very best art history
department in the United States can
begin to project itself into a much into
a much wider community it's one thing to
deal with a picture which is a
two-dimensional surface using images
projected on a on a wall a building does
not respond so readily to that kind of
that kind of image intellectually the
subject of my current book and my
current research really has to do with
the process of becoming and the process
of change the phenomenon by which one
thing becomes another yes the kind of
partnerships that one finds within the
framework of a project like this are
rewarding amusing entertaining wonderful
the creative forum that we had
established to make the Emmy a project
that includes eden muir and rory o'neill
and our other colleagues across campus
has been one of the most rewarding
frameworks really that i've encountered
since coming to columbia of what's good
of the thing with the different types of
projects that are going on at columbia
right now the america Theed relie has
really planted a flag on top of a
mountain and has demonstrated that not
only is the cooperation between
departments potentially a wonderful
thing
but more generally that
these technologies are not just things
that should remain in the sphere of the
film industry or specialty industries
but can can come to bear on a wide
variety of fields and show a big promise
for the future of Education where our
telecommunications and electronic
distribution of these materials becomes
important and essential actually and
that if you take something like art
history which you don't normally
associate with special effects and
high-tech and mix it with this there is
the possibility that that it will bring
this type of information to a very large
audience and a fun and
easy-to-understand way and that this
could have be happening in all
departments well the the process was
fascinating because we had to generate
22,000 frames of full screen video which
is something that no school of
architecture has ever done before and
probably will never do again it was a
remarkable experience first of all we
had to do the the brunt of the rendering
which is the really difficult task after
final exams were passed and final
reviews were over it meant basically
taking over every machine in the
building putting it toward this task as
well as engaging in collaborative
arrangements with the School of
Engineering to get their large machines
rendering for us overnight so for a
period of several weeks we had every
Silicon Graphics station on campus
working for us including the two giant
supercomputers at engineering so
literally what was happening was every
day we were going downtown on the subway
several times with a very large hard
drive containing four gigabytes of high
resolution images and these were being
dumped to tape well the omnia project
has been a testbed for us in order to
experiment with new imaging techniques
with producing video on a great
Cathedral to animate the cathedral with
Softimage an advanced animation package
to create moving images because we've
never had moving images in the classroom
before at Columbia in teaching art
history
we found that that is particularly
effective and bringing three-dimensional
objects like a great Cathedral across
the students many of whom probably have
never seen a cathedral like omnia before